ها هو يضرب بيديه على الطاوله سنخوض
المعركه مع روسيا مهما حدث ومهما سيحدث كم
يعلنها امام العالم يا ساده وبخيبه امل
كيف تتحدث لن تكون لنا نهايه سعيده في
الهجوم المضاد والمعارك تشتعل في الميدان
بضراوه
في طاوله واحده يشعلان العالم بقرارات
مصيريه وانزلنسكي كعادته يرشق سهام
الخيانه تجاه الامم المتحده فما الذي يجري
والسعوديه تنشر خارطه جديده لبلادها معلنه
عن ابتلاع الجزيره التيران وصل وبماذا
سترد ام الدنيا ووجه الغراب ونقصد العالم
الهولندي يظهر من جديد ليثير الجدل ويتنبا
بزلزل جديده سيحدث احدها في بلد عربي وفي
الجهه المقابله عداد الضحايا لا يتوقف عن
الدوران في المغرب بينما تعيش ليبيا ما هو
اسوا وال
[موسيقى]
لكن ما الذي يخططونه
بلقاء كهذا وهو سؤال طرح على بوتين بطريقه
اخرى عما اذا كانت روسيا ستساعد كوريا
الشماليه في بناء الاقمار الصناعيه ليرد
بقوله هذا هو السبب الذي اتينا من اجله
الى قاعده فسوشني الفضائيه
انا الذي ترونه انتم وفي اوكرانيا اعترف
رئيسها فلود مرزيلين
[موسيقى]
فقد الكثير من جنود في ساحه المعركه وماذا
عن بقيه من سيفقدهم
هل سيكون الامر مجديا حينها ليجيب وزير
الدفاع الروسي سيرجيو مؤكدا انه ليس لدى
روسيا اي خيار اخر غير تحقيق انتصار في
عمليه العسكريه الخاصه في اوكرانيا ليعود
ويغير اتجاه بوصله نحو الامم المتحده هذه
المره فقد اتهم الرئيس الاوكراني الامم
المتحده بعدم الرغبه في الضغط على روسيا
واشار الى ان الدول الاعضاء في المنظمه
تهتم بالعلاقات الاقتصاديه اكثر من
اهتمامها بالقيم هل وصلت الى مرحله ان
يوجه الاتهامات لاصدقائه قبل اعدائه يا
لغرابه الموقف وبالعوده الى الميدان
الاوكراني قال رئيس هيئه الاركان العامه
للقوات المسلحه البريطانيه
انه لا يكاد يصدق ما يحدث لحقيقه فقدان
قوات نظام كييف اربعين بالمئه من المسيرات
بسبب الاخطاء المرتكبه من مشغلي وها هو
المصدر يتحدث ونحن نتصفحه امامكم في موقع
وكاله العالميه جانبها قالت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ان اوكرانيا هجمت ميناء
سيلفاستوبول لبناء السفن في شبه جزيره
القرم بعشره صواريخ كروز وثلاثه
قيد الاصلاح واندلع حريق في مصنع للسفن في
المقابل القناه الجيش الاوكراني ان
دفاعاته الجويه اسقطت 32 مسيره من اصل 44
اطلقتها القوات الروسيه على مقاطعه اوديسا
وهي بيانات وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اليوميه
تكشف ان مجموع الخسائر البشريه التي
تكبدها الجيش الاوكراني خلال 24 ساعه قد
بلغت نحو 810 عسكريين والعهده على المصدر
كما نتصفحه الان في الموقع الرسمي للحكومه
الروسيه ومن رائحه الموت والبارود على
قائمه الدعم والمساعدات حيث افادت قناه
فاكس نيوز نقلا عن وثيقه البيت الابيض بان
الولايات المتحده انفقت اكثر من 100 مليار
دولار على دعم اوكرانيا بينما تراجعت
المانيا عن مساعداتها قليلا فبعد ان تم
الاعلان عن اربعين مركبه مجاه سلمت برلين
لنظام كييف 20 مركبه مشاه قتاليه اخرى من
طراز ماردر محمله بالذخيره خلال اسبوع
ليصل اجمالي عدد المركبات من هذا النوع
التي قدمت برلين الى 60 قطعه ما الذي
يعنيه هذا التراجع الالماني هل هي ضغوطات
روسيه الاجابه لكم والان الى الاحداث
والتطورات نشرت المملكه السعوديه خارطتها
الرسميه
مصر على نقل ملكيتهما الى المملكه واعطت
السعوديه تسميه مختلفه قليلا عن المتعارف
عليه الى الجزيرتين اطلقت صنافر على
صنافير وثيرا على ثيران ودعت الى اعتماد
الخارطه في المحافل والمؤسسات كافه بينما
اشتد حنقل المصريين بعد رؤيه اراضيهم تذهب
من ايديهم بل انتهت القضيه هم ان للمصريين
رايا اخر غيبت السيول احياء كامله في
مدينه دارنا الليبيه وقتلت الاف الاشخاص
وتحدثت التقارير عن الاف المفقودين وسط
تباين في تقديرات الاعداد الفعليه للقتل
لحين طلبت السلطات اسباب المساعده في
الانقاذ ترتفع حصيله ضحايا السيول
والفيضانات التي اجتاحت مدينه درنه بسبب
إسار دانيال الذي ضرب البلاد الى خمسه
الاف وثلاثمائه قتيل وفق اخر احصائيه صدرت
عن وزاره الداخليه وقال المسؤول الاعلامي
بالوزاره محمد ابو لموشه ان حصيله القتل
ضخمه وقد تصل الى الالاف وان عدد
المفقودين وصل الى نحو عشره
اللهم الطف بمن تبقى وارحم من مات من
اخواننا في ليبيا اعصار دانيال توسع قليلا
ليخرج من ليبيا الى السودان وهناك نهار
نحو خمسين منزلا بالكامل في منطقه جادوب
ولايه نهر النيل شمالي البلاد فيا لها من
ماساه انسانيه والى المغرب حيث تتواصل
عمليات البحث عن ناجين من زلزال منطقه
الحوز وقد بلغ عدد القتلى نحو ثلاثه الاف
بينما تجاوز عدد الجرح خمسه الاف وخمسمائه
هذا وتشهد المرافق الصحيه في مختلف
المناطق المتضرره تعبئه شامله لتقديم
العلاجات اللازمه للناجين هذا ويتوقع عالم
الزلازل الهولندي فرانكو
خلال ايام في ثلاث دول بينها دوله عربيه
وهي البرتغال واسبانيا والمغرب وكل منه في
الساحل لانه قد يكون هناك نشاط زلزالي
كبير
الى كارثه وفق قوله ولا زلنا في زلزال
المغرب وبعد رفض الرباط الدعم الفرنسي
لمساعده ضحايا الزلزال والرئيس الفرنسي
ايمانويل يخاطب المغاربه مجددا استعداد
بلاده لتقديم يد العون الى المغرب
بشان العلاقات بين باريس والرباط بعد
امتناع السلطات المغربيه قبل مساعدات
عرضتها عليها فرنسا اثر الزلزال المدمر
اعلن رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي بالموقع
انه وجه بفتح تحقيق بعزل الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن على خلفيه شبهات بتورطه في قضايا
فساد فليجتمع رئيسان في السجن للمره
الاولى وهما رئيس الحالي والرئيس السابق
عن اي ازمه امريكيه اتحدث
[موسيقى]